DW тут на саміті НАТО у Вільнюсі а поруч
зі мною Ганна Губко колишня депутатка
Верховної Ради
нині громадські активістка експертка з
міжнародних питань і співзаснов
співзасновниця міжнародного центру
української Перемоги День добрий Отже Ми
сьогодні підіб'ємо підсумки саміту про
що домовилися про що не домовилися я би
коротко сказав що це такі своєрідне було
запрошення без запрошення тобто з одного
боку технічно НАТО не проти технічного
запросили Україну але офіційного
запрошення не було про це ми зрештою і
поговоримо Отже пані Ганно на вашу думку
які головні підсумки Самі того Ну як ви
правильно сказали що запрошення немає
але зате нам сказали що вже не буде два
етапи а буде пришвидшена процедура тому
що не потрібно пдч з одної сторони ніби
обнадіяли для себе знайшли виправдання
щоб зберегти обличчя що це Альянс
рішучих а не переляканих що якщо вони
ухвалять таке рішення і самі міг би бути
історичним з точки зору зобов'язань що
ми надаючи формальне запрошення
починаємо всі процедури щодо подальшого
вступу Action України в НАТО За
прикладом Фінляндії як це було
майже впродовж року тому очевидно
українські плани може нас хтось називав
мрійниками що ми розраховували що НАТО
зробить висновки із саміту в бухаресті в
2008 році тому що тоді нерішучість
відсутність політичної волі для Грузії і
для України
Ющенка це теж було справді нерішуючись з
боку спереду все західної країни США
Німеччина Франція тоді і зараз до речі
позиція Франції змінилася вже остаточно
чи вони декларативно перед самі Там
закликали надати запрошення якраз ми
бачимо наскільки на різних самі різні
члени Альянсу займають позиції деякі
навіть протилежні від того що тому що в
бухаресті Сполучені Штати Америки якраз
мали жорстку позицію Зараз ми бачимо що
адміністрація байдена і Байден особисто
наводили
ряд аргументів з якими ми не
погоджуємося і навіть сьогодні Джейк
Салліван відповідаючи на запитання Дарії
Каленюк
з питань національної безпеки Білого
дому
почав трохи маніпулятивно говорити що
членство України в НАТО означає війну
НАТО з російської Федерацією по-перше
в завтрашнього дня Тобто Це ж коли
будуть безпекові умови от тому ми Якраз
зараз не зробити запрошення розставити
крапки над і потім рухатися далі от тому
Якраз це якась дезінформація тому що
формальне запрошення сьогодні не означає
членство Завтра є ряд процедур і Україна
навіть коли йшлося про фаст трек не
вимагала щоб Візьміть на завтра і бо ми
вже хочемо Ні ми розуміємо що є е-е
Фактор війни І багато хто чекає поки
Україна переможе і тоді двері справді
будуть відчиненими буде інша розмова але
це формальне запрошення воно має вагоме
вплив на завершення війни саме перемогою
України це потужний сигнал для
інвесторів і перебуваючи недавно в
Берліні коли ми зустрічалися із
німецьким бізнесом вони підтримували
якраз надання Україні формального
запрошення і наш рух до НАТО розуміючи
що це і для них потужні гарантії на
майбутнє тому ми повинні чесно сказати
що всі ці запевнення що Україна і чітко
там нам кажуть сьогодні багато партнерів
які бачать розчарування на нашому
обличчі кажуть ви що це такий прогрес ми
стверджувально сказали що Україна буде
членом НАТО але
розумієте і тому Насправді
Я би дуже хотіла щоб більше міжнародних
делегацій приїжджали не в Київ бо Київ
попри постійні атаки все одно він
віддалений від того що відбувається від
цього пекло яке є зараз на передовій
тому що це якраз ціна яку ми платимо за
помилки в 2008 році і найгірше насаменті
в бухаресті НАТО і за помилки які за ці
спочатку 8 років спроб
політико-дипломатичного врегулювання
призвели до геноциду нагадаємо що самі
над бухаресті 2008 році був у квітні а
напад на Грузію був у серпні того ж року
Тобто про що ми говоримо що пдч зрештою
деяки мали би надати і Грузії і Україні
могло все ж таки змінити хід історії як
на мене і можливо ми уникнули тоді
нападу і зараз але повертаючись до
саміту НАТО тут і про реакцію
Зеленського напередодні самі То коли він
був в дорозі сюди у Вільнюс е-е
президент доволі різко е-е сказав про
НАТО розкритикував казав що треба на
добути рішучими нарешті вже визначитися
і не не займати Таку позицію що
захід готовий до переговорів з Росією і
шантажувати оце вступить Україна в НАТО
чи не вступить щоб грати от щоб Україна
знову стала розмінною монетою зараз коли
він тут вже от щойно закінчили цього
прес-конференція якраз теж там був на і
по ньому було видно що він в принципі
задоволений рішенням саме то він сказав
що результати гарні але не ідеальні
ідеальні Це коли було офіційне
запрошення виглядав доволі впевнено в
принципі знову ж таки жартував е-е вони
там обнімалися ручками із генсеком НАТО
на вашу думку чи справді результати
саміту е-е
гарної сказав президент що можна
підсумувати Ну насправді давайте чесно
говорити немає результатів Самі того
хлопця Ну це 15 років ну 15 років ми
зараз переживаємо як нація геноцид ви
знаєте за століття це другий геноцид
один під час Радянського Союзу створений
Сталіним і зараз Російська Федерація
чинить тому такий простий крок як
надання формального запрошення який ні
до чого не зобов'язував це не втілення
відразу статті п'ятої Тому я хочу щоб ми
говорили відверто що ми розраховували на
міцну підтримку і потужний сигнал до
ворога до держави-агресора що Україна не
буферна Свобода але
президент насправді я їх розумію що йому
треба
мати можливості комунікації і західними
лідерами тому що давайте розділимо НАТО
і наші членство і поточні пріоритетні
завдання питання забезпечення збройних
сил
винищувачами далекобійними системами
тому що крім наступу нам треба
готуватись до наступного наступу тому що
це запрошення воно розглядається як
частина стратегії з української Перемоги
так само як нам кажуть От f-16 і що все
ви переможете кластерні боєприпаси
атакам це і так далі тому ми хотіли щоб
на заході нарешті була сміливість а мати
стратегію української Перемоги яка має
кілька компонентів які важливі
пришвидшення поставок озброєння в тих
масштабах які потрібні для цього захід
тоді надають чіткий сигнали Росії і так
далі тим самим він себе зобов'язує
надавати більше зброї яку він теж Вона
закінчується так був початкі сигнал все
ж таки і війна Я думаю закінчилася чого
боїться закиди просте запитання чого
боїться захід і не надає дитині
запрошення навіть в форматі є кілька
бачень одне збачень - Це ті страшилки і
це прикрочувати тому що російська
економіка Вона менше економіки Італії чи
штату одного штату в Сполучених Штатах
Америки
ядерний шантаж Я думаю що ви країн НАТО
які є ядерними державами є можливість
послати ті сигнали і так далі тому ми
багато чуємо про якісь спроби посадити
Україну за стіл перемовин Back channels
і мені б дуже не хотілося щоб ми
потрапляли в якийсь капкан там чи Мінськ
три чи ще щось Тобто це є натяк західну
заходу для Росії щодо переговорів чи ні
те що тобто що вони От бачите ми не
надали Україні запрошення давайте якось
тепер крок з вашого боку і е-е я дуже
сподіваюся що
Україна зокрема в цьому емоційному пості
нашого президента позиції
тобто був в дорозі сюди який критичний
посилає чіткий сигнал що ми як нація
переживаємо геноцид і ми хочемо більше
рішучості біб-рейв А з Ukrainian Arm
Forces будьте такі ж відважні як
Українські збройні сили тому що де-факто
ЗСУ - це армія Європи де-факто ми вже
східний план Я хочу говорити що ми щит
Ні нам потрібні щити щоб захистити себе
і не дозволити агресії вийти за
територію України тому що при такому
підході дуже слабких поставок озброєння
у війні на виснаження в Україні немає
можливостей перемогти а це означає що ми
будемо далі стікати кров'ю в той час як
на таких прекрасних самітах будуть
обговорювати А як ще через там півроку
рік поставити те що нам треба було на
позавчора тому успіх НАТО успіх наших
стратегічних партнерів був би в тому щоб
запобігти повномасштабному вторгненню А
ще найкраще щоб взагалі в 2014 року не
було початку збройних агресії Тому треба
Але висновки ніхто не зробив і зараз
коли ми говоримо про безпекові обіцянки
зобов'язання я не наважу сказати
гарантії тому що ми вивчили всі
будапештські меморандум висновки немає
ніяких Вибачте гарантії не було Це були
і то навіть деякі наші партнери кажуть А
в нашому англійському тексті звучить
запевнення ми вам гарантії не обіцяли
Навіть таке тому ми би хотіли бачити
справжні лідерство не виродження
сміливих людей які не бояться як Рейган
тому байдуги
я дуже сподіваюся що ми побачимо
колективне лідерство у вигляді
пришвидшення української Перемоги це є
надважливим виборів
на це рішення є багато думок Ну як хтось
припускає з оглядачів що можливо
наступну рік це Ювілейний саміт НАТО 75
який має відбутися у Вашингтоні цей рік
виборів можливо цим скористається
демократична партія Байден там не знаю в
якихось своїх політичних цілях і так
далі наскільки впливають вибори на оце
яке було тут на саміті і на потенційно
наступну і саміту Вашингтону треба
говорити не лише про вибори в Сполучених
Штатах Америки вибори в європарламенті
вибори на РФ вибори в Молдові в Тайвані
скрізь будуть в Індії парламентські тому
в мене би дуже не хотілося бути
заручником виборчих процесів в світі
Тому очевидно коли Минулого року генерал
залужний говорив про потреби армії після
успішного контрнаступу в Херсоні на
Харківщині дайте нам все необхідне нас
згодували обіцянками що все буде на
початок
весни цього року що ми зможемо вже
втілити Ми не отримали того всього що
нам обіцяли І тому ми маємо такі зараз
заяви вплинуть вибори за Фактор виборів
президента
критично важливо зберегти двопартійну
підтримку і Я дуже сподіваюся що конгрес
буде проявляти історичну мудрість
розуміючи важливу місію душа як лідери
вільного світу в допомозі України Це є
важливо але я розумію що будуть сили які
захочуть втягнути Україну і Тому
очевидно треба пришвидшити перемогу
України і як кажуть генерали що Крим це
абсолютно чи вибил гол ну ці яку можна
досягнути якщо до кінця цього року і це
було би ідеально перемога до кінця цього
року Господи благословив 23-му році щоб
потім уже всі Видихнули і фокусувалися
Ну і це буде сигнал іншим авторитарним
режимом і це буде реальний лідерство і
тоді я думаю уже на саміті Вашингтоні
оскільки нам тут сказали що вас
скорочена процедура вже не треба два
назви уже Україна переможець зможе
зробити НАТО не просто
[музика]
транзатлантичною організацією яка а
зробить глобальним гравцем для протидії
стриманню авторитаризму так і от НАТО
подає як один з політичних досягнень
результатів самі то це саме створення
комісії замість комісії Україна НАТО
ради НАТО як оцей формат замість комісії
рада
він впливає на те щоб ця мета була
досягнута на прес-конференції єнс
Столтенберг кілька разів казав ікл тобто
рівні рівні тобто що всі там будуть
рівні і Україна також буде рівною
наскільки це правда і наскільки ця рада
посприяє вступу України в НАТО Коли
Україна стане повноправним членом НАТО
тоді я скажу Так це круглий стіл рівних
серед рівних в когось може бути кращий
досвід як в України бойовий з унікальним
застосуванням і Дельта система кроповий
і так далі Тобто ми приходимо в НАТО з
Як то кажуть з таким можливостями
посилити Альянс Тому це буде рівний
серед рівних зараз на шляху до нашого
повноправного членства це один з
інструментів для обговорення питань
проблемних які є Ось але ми себе не
будемо обманювати і казати що це рівний
серед рівних навіть якщо в пу воно
звучить красиво ми розуміємо що це один
може бути досягнути на цій раді що вона
може прослуховувати що воно може
ініціювати якісь обговорення надання
зброї не знаю тобто наприклад є
двостороння співпраця і зокрема тут
Норвегія дала нові зобов'язання про
допомогу
Франція так само свої далекобійні
системи от Німеччина патріоти і так далі
Тобто це те що ми так працювали але
колективно від НАТО Ми хочемо більшого
Ось і це більше це наша членство ми
будемо використовувати Раду Україна НАТО
там є президентські рівень чи рівень
главдержав міністерський
посольський і експертний Очевидно це
можливості доносити нагальні питання як
буде брати участь у
розговорить ми проводимо наша мережа Анс
вже втретє молодіжну модель
парламентської асамблеї НАТО ми вже
підготували близько 500 молодих
євроатлантистів які знають як функціонує
панато Тобто ми я б хотіла наприклад
порушувати питання де мілітаризації
Чорного моря тому що зернова угода не є
вирішенням Росія завжди є важелі впливу
саботажу блокування нашого експорту і це
призводить до того що мільйони країн
глобального півня недоотримують
українське зерно і не тільки Тому
очевидно нам треба ставити питання Чорне
море це море домінанти Російської
Федерації це це море країн НАТО і ЄС
тому якщо ця рада на різних рівнях ми
будемо пришвидшувати якісь процеси
ухвалювати важливі рішення Окей на шляху
до інтеграції це важливий інструмент але
ми чекаємо запрошення Ми чекаємо клериті
ясності що мало на увазі Коли Україна
буде відповідати цим вимогам
таке різна тлумачення слова вимоги і я
нагадаю що от Зеленський щойно на
прес-конференції сказав що це безпекові
вимоги тобто він сказав що він все
бачить так що як коли буде безпека на
території України а При цьому до цього
заявляли західні країни що йдеться і про
е-е виконання реформ які боротьба з
корупцією судова реформа і так далі І
так далі тобто зрештою це треба чекати
Виконання всіх цих реформ ми знаємо що
багато країн вступили в НАТО без
виконання цих
вимог і були не менш корумповані ніж
Україна
не хочу ображати Чи якось там називати
перелічувати ці країни але багато країн
східної Центральної Європи не виконали в
чистому вигляді багато
колишня голова комітету закордонної
справа з етичних міркування з того що
нам потрібна буде підтримка і консенсус
я не буду називати якісь країни але
подвійні стандарти все-таки є коли є
геополітична доцільність бачите якусь
країну в НАТО тоді з'являються всі
займаються всі
НАТО і ніхто не розказував про частину
тоді
Спокійно що ми хочемо вже беріть нас
зараз НАТО ми говоримо про запрошення
про те що ми будемо дотримуватися всіх
процедур всього алгоритму вступу тому
тут ми ж не кажемо Візьміть нас вже
завтра нас гаряча фаза війни тому що ви
знаєте от це коли нам не дають
запрошення це ніби як сумнів А чи здатні
ви виграти війну а давайте ми подивимося
якщо будуть успіхи на полі бою тоді ми
швиденько до вас бо всі люблять
переможців і ми зразу будемо з вами і
тоді ви в НАТО і все Але ми не хочемо
йти в НАТО коли війна триватиме ще
кілька років Або можливо нам
запропонують сценарій замороження чи
Мінськ три після всього пережито ми
хочемо справедливого покарання Ми хочемо
трибуналу Ми хочемо виплати репарації Ми
хочемо йде імпералізації РФ
зрозуміло Отже глядачі зараз хотів би
подякувати пані Гані і в нас є ще один
сюрприз для вас поруч зі мною
так зірка пані Дарія Каленюк яка
поговоримо з нею е-е про те які ж умови
все ж таки потрібно виконати Україні
Будь ласка Ми в прямому ефірі будь ласка
доєднуйтесь до нас
Отже Дарія Калинюк центр протидії
корупції також експертка з міжнародних
питань Отже Розкажіть будь ласка про
умови ми говорили і Зеленський і західні
країни вони і бачать різне розуміння
умов так ну принаймні акцент робить
президент на безпеку в умовах коли буде
безпека в Україні західні країни кажуть
Ні почекайте є ще умови боротьба з
корупцією ваша тема там сидова реформи і
так далі Отже які умови має виконати
зараз Україна пдчя прибрали але є умови
і це розмите поняття
не знаю не знаю саме тому ми
критикуємо це формулювання
якщо
НАТО вважає що в Україні потрібно
виконати якісь умови Скажіть ми
виконували умови в рамках річного плану
оцінки були великі документи на 300
сторінок ніхто ці документи сьогодні не
читав не було жодного інструменту від
НАТО щоби оцінювати виконання цих реформ
ми як громадянське суспільство не могли
навіть покластися на ці документи тому
що там настільки все було
незрозуміло е-е написано Ну ми працюємо
з умовами міжнародних партнерів більше
10 років ми знаємо як виглядають умови з
чітким дедлайном з чітким формулюванням
і які ну реально втілити в життя тобто є
умови ЄС немає документів
тобто пдч як е слушно висловився Кулеба
Міністр закордонних справ сказав що
зрештою Україна шлях України до НАТО
став коротшим Бо немає пчя але довшим
тобто фактично
оця от розмитність формулювань
незрозуміло що треба виконувати щоб
карантинних воно і подовшує вступу
країни НАТО абсолютно і це дуже не
прагматично з точки зору НАТО тому що
якби дійсно було бажання в НАТО аби
Україна виконала якісь умови в галузі
антикорупції і хорошого врядування то
було б були б описані ці умови вони були
б чітко сформульовані і уряд би отримав
інформацію про ці умови була би
надіслана або би якісь механізми
аналізу виконання цих умов якісь
експерти були б надіслані Ну наприклад
була аби умова
підвищити прозорість ефективність
закупівель оборонних закупівель зокрема
зброї в Україні
в кулуатах В кулуарах
деякі експерти говорять що Ну напевно
НАТО мало на увазі це Але ми не знаємо
що вони мали на увазі так
тому ми не можемо скористатися навіть
цим формулювання як ми робили наприклад
з умовами стосовно інтеграції ЄС дуже
була схожа ситуація минулого червня коли
ми адвокатували кандидатство України до
Європейського Союзу і різним столицям
їздила Нам казали так Ви ж дуже
корумпована країна ми казали ну що
значить корумпована Звичайно у нас є
корупція ми зараз знаємо але ми купа
всього зробили Подивіться ми працювали
останні 10 років над реформами набу сап
антикорупційний суд система декларування
прозоро Ну давайте з вами подумаємо що
потрібно що зробити ми вважаємо як
громадянське суспільство що треба
призначити спецпрокурора брати директора
набу і ми з ними вели переговори що
реалістично в Україні виконати але ми їх
попросили спочатку дайте нам
кандидатство а потім чіткі умови і вони
це зробили чому НАТО так не зробили тоді
не знаю тому що не було бажання щоб
Україна здійснила реформи Я думаю А було
бажання мати зручну відмаз що Україна
сама винна що немає зараз запрошення в
НАТО а це не так але деякі експерти все
ж таки стверджують що технічну Україну
запросили в НАТО бо дивіться там рівень
співпраці там замість комісії рада потім
довгострокові програми мають бути щодо
приведення українського армії до
стандартів НАТО там навчанні і так далі
І так далі
знову ж таки це вже не просто відкриті
двері до НАТО як на бухарецькому саме
тоді це вже широко відкриті ворота да
але принаймні немає все одно запрошення
да ніхто не знає як туди заїхати Там
деякі міні поля напруги і так далі ніхто
не знає де вони є тобто все відкрито
кватирки ворота двері навіть у підвал
але ніхто не знає де ж цей будинок де
вхід Де цей портал знаходиться на вашу
думку гарантії безпеки от на цей період
поки все це відбувається якими вони
можуть бути Тобто це лише на
двосторонній основі там Україна США
україна-франція Україна Британія яким
чином Зараз ми побачили на саміті те що
оголошення наприклад від Франції про
далекобійні ракети да про що вони раніше
не говорили тільки Британії їх надала
надала Їх навіть Америка не надала їх
Німеччина категорично проти а Франція
яка вважалася більш-менш ну такою
стриманою холодною в цьому питанні вона
надала Тобто про що це свідчить цей
сигнал
мені причосу особливо це не свідчить
насправді ми слідкували в першу чергу за
американцями і вони багато говорять про
гарантії безпеки альтернативні до НАТО
зокрема ізраїльську модель але
замовчують про те що в ізраїльські
моделі попри те що є щорічне
фінансування
зброї на кілька мільярдів доларів для
Ізраїлю
є в Ізраїлю ще ядерна зброя і американці
закрили очі на розробку цієї ядерної
зброї Тому це секрет що в Ізраїлі ядерна
зброя Ну але офіційно Ізраїль каже що на
зброю ядерної немає але коли було буде
потрібно мені застосуємо і мовчазна
згода американців при цьому і треба
врахувати що вороги Ізраїлю жодних з них
немає ядерної зброї в Україні в Україні
насправді зовсім протилежна історія наш
ворог має ядерну зброю Ми не маємо
який яка ізраїльська модель може
працювати
фінансування питання надалі нам
військовою допомоги
Чи це є гарантією безпеки це гарантія
того що ми не помремо відразу це
гарантія того що буде це вся історія
тривати ще певний час поки в нас не
завершиться солдати але ми на багатьох
зустрічах в кулуарах ми запитували
шановні пані та панове А що ви будете
робити як НАТО і кожна з ваших країн
коли в Україні завершиться солдати Чи ви
е-е
країни можливо свої війська потім таки
нададуть Тобто Це звісно ніхто Офіційно
про це не говорить але принаймні в
кулуарах таке обговорювалося що можливо
деякі країни Східної Європи які особливо
не будуть перелічувати їх особливо
підтримують Україну потенційно можуть
розглядати введення якихось окремих
контингентів можливо відставників тимче
когось
на підтримку Це не зовсім континенти але
постійно
- Це дійсно
країна з якою ми там домовляємось
співпрацюємо надсилає нам
частину своїх збройних сил і частина
своєї військової
сили у вигляді зброї цього поки що я не
бачу бажання і готовності жодної країни
цього зробити тобто людський фактор ми
зараз людські ресурс Ми не можемо
працювати
для кількох Я не знаю там років Це буде
дуже невигідно дуже дорого для наших
партнерів НАТО найдешевший спосіб для
них захиститися це взяти Україну в НАТО
і ми це пояснюємо тому що
неправильно говорити що це питання лише
стосується безпеки України питання
стосується загалом Безпеки Європи
безпеки НАТО і без безпеки світового
порядку Росія воює не з Україною Росія
воює з НАТО і з цінностями демократії
Ось але просто захищається цінності
захищаються цінності тільки українці е-е
і їх підтримують допомагають наші
партнери які надають нам зброю а-а і
гроші Ось але просто українці Можуть
закінчитися хто тоді буде захищати
демократичний порядок хто тоді буде
захищати НАТО від їхнього найрізнішого
ворога і запитання логічно вони якщо
вони рахують і гроші вони рахують і
ризики безпеки для себе і так далі чому
не надати швидше ті саме така інше відео
озброєння які зараз негайно потребує
Україну особливо під час Контрнаступ що
їх тоді стримує якщо бути нарешті літаки
Я знаю що ви на f16 на цій темі дуже
спеціалізуйтеся ми зараз про це
поговоримо давайте зараз е-е трохи
розділимо літаки буде другим запитанням
А зараз все ж таки про зброю да далеко
про далекобійну зброю зараз Контрнаступ
це дуже необхідно давати надавати
наносити удари завдавати ударів по
складах по скупченню живої сили і
техніки і так далі чому це не робиться
чому британці дали обмежену кількість
зараз обмежена кількість від французів
німці категорично проти американці теж
начебто є просування за таким сами але
поки що їх немає офіційно Чому вони у
кожного українця Я впевнений виникає
запитання Чому захід так повільно надає
зброю ви в товаристві спілкувалися
бояться чого він аж швидше ж може
закінчитися тоді бояться що Росія почне
ескалацію Що таке ескалація ніхто не
знала куди далі
чи взагалі працює в них це ядерна зброя
чи ні це окреме питання для чого
росіянам лупити ядерною зброєю по Європі
І починати третю світову ядерну війну
якщо в них Всі діти навчаються в країнах
НАТО також ніхто на це питання не може
відповісти
але на нього клюють досі досі клюють і
це роки
ядерний і це використовується Ну якщо
подивитися на
то що говорив сьогодні Джейк саліван то
основна причина чому мене рухаємося далі
по НАТО тому що це означатиме вступ
України в НАТО означатиме що відразу
Америка починає війну з Росією ось А
чому вони не хочуть починати війну з
Росією Хоча вони вели війну в Іраку в
Афганістані Ну тому що вона ядерна
держава і от це буде загроза третій
світової війни ядерної ось Тому цей
страх і досі бояться саме ядерного
правильно
якщо Росія програє також бояться тобто
вони не можуть прорахувати що буде з
Росією цією величезною терито так під
чим контролем буде ядерна зброя і так
далі відбувається
стратегічна загроза ніж сама Росія
їх під контролем Китаю Для офіційно Але
тим не менше так тобто немає готовності
того щоб Україна перемогла Я не кажу що
Україні Немає потреби робити свою
homework І от я повернуся в п'ятницю у
нас команда в Києві працює над
моніторингом і Збройних закупівель і ми
працюємо над тим щоб змушувати наше
Міністерство оборони не просто їздити по
конференціям робити свою роботу
управляти міністерством робити Ну дуже
такі технічні речі ось це потрібно
робити і ми будемо це вже робимо Будемо
далі це робити але це не є основною
причини рішення цього саме то не
запрошувати Україну в НАТО основна
причина - це страх В першу чергу страх в
Білому домі і якась Надія в Білому домі
що
з Росією можна домовитися що треба
лишати ці переговори з Росією що вони
все ж таки погодяться на якусь мирну
угоду що
[музика]
може бути якийсь там всі спайки тобто ну
заморозка конфлікту Тобто ми підуть
українці впевнений Ми ідемо сценарію
Мінську 2 ну це буде Мінськ 3 так який
буде катастрофічний для України так і
для НАТО в тому числі катастрофічний а
йдемо фактично на чолі цього процесу в
Сполучені Штати які скажуть тоді мають
свої пеклі такі задні контакти Скажімо
так неофіційні контакти і відповідно
намагаються допомоги
Тобто це питання
чому чому немає цього запрошення Чи це
страх що Україна переможе страх що Росія
програє Чи це бажання мати -3 і На жаль
в більшості експертів Білого дому є таке
відчуття що
Росія має таку потужну силу як мав
Радянський Союз що це супердержава
Вони досі голова на жаль так На жаль так
вони не розуміють що таке Кремль Вони не
розуміють що їхня основна мотивація
мотивація лишатися при владі і
користуватися своїм награбованим майном
яке вони порозпорошували по всьому світу
що абсолютно більшості Кремля Окей
закінчити цю війну якщо вони залишиться
при владі Що Чим більше вони програють
на полі бою чим більше вони втрат
зазнають чим сильніші жорсткіші санкції
і тим більше мотивації в них завершити
цю війну але чим більше на поступки йде
НАТО чим більше от слабкість
проявляється і нерішуючись тим більше
вони далі будуть йти в Контрнаступ Тим
більше вони далі будуть бити по
українських е-е українські критичні
інфраструктурі
будуть тримати українців як заручників
шантажуючи підривом запорізької атомної
станції ось Ну якщо дозволити
гопніку просто розійтися а не дати йому
поносі то він далі може начудити
наламати дров
умовно піти і там вже
Отже повертаючись до теми f16 ви багато
зробите в цій темі стежити за ці теми
Отже літаки чому зараз навіть досі ще
фактично розпочалось навіть навчання Не
кажучи вже про передання цих літаків в
Україні чому така затримка з таким
важливим процесом мені чесно кажучи
вдавалося що Навчання вже йде але просто
Офіційно про це не оголошується з різних
міркувань але пілотів готують чи не
готуючись що із того що я чую реально
навчання досвідчених українських
льотчиків може початися не раніше січня
2024 року січень 2024 року
і це дуже печально і знову ж таки
Причина в тому що ця технологія належить
сполученим штатам Америки
вони є власниками найбільшого
повітряного флоту з f-16
і будь-яке навчання Вони мають
погоджувати вони погоди навчання для
українців але інструкторів в Європі мало
тобто дачани їхні інструктори котрі
мають ліцензію навчати наф-16 Вони тепер
самі навчаються на 35-х і
немає Європа не була готова як нам
зробити так як провести це навчання щоб
воно було і сертифіковано по
американським стандартам і щоб це
зробити швидко і тому от Вони шукають
різні варіанти бюрократія фактично і так
далі просто спостерігають тобто в ту
сані в арізонні є військова база де
навчаються іноземних пілотів де наші
двоє пілотів приходили так званий СС
Тобто де намагалися зрозуміти наскільки
швидко наші пилити можуть навчитися і
прийшли до висновку 4-6 місяців цього
достатньо але на цій базі хто сьогодні
навчаються
пілоти іноземних країн також з країн Ну
і в 16-х з країн Східної Європи
які можливо менш критично потрібно ці я
в 16-ти ніж нам але
українці там не навчаються і На жаль
ми не бачимо лідерства зі сторони
Сполучених Штатів Тобто це ще одна
свідчення того що на жаль Сполучені
Штати теж намагаються використати цю
ситуацію щоб домовитися з Росією тоді чи
ні тобто Вони не зацікавлені пришвидшити
це з одного однією рукою вони дають
зброю іншою рукою вони домовляються чи
яким чином тобто Україна знову
заложується геополітики бруднує
геополітики але ми цього разу
І ну ви знаєте ми працюємо тісно з
нашими партнерами більше 10 років над
питаннями антикорупції верховенства
права і коли
почалася широкомасштабне ми почали дуже
відверто дискутувати з нашими партнерами
Ну давайте давайте говорити правду
нам в 2014 році казали не вимагайте
зброї
домовляйтеся З терористами робіть
реформи ми все робили як нам казали ми
довіряли ось а в результаті
почалися почався геноцид Російської
Федерації ось тепер ми вже говоримо Ми
називаємо речі своїми іменами ми
говоримо Ну ми ж знаємо що ви
домовляєтесь з росіянами
такого не дипломатичного підходу да на
такі більш відвертий воно якось впливає
на західний партнерів якщо ми прямо в
очі кажуть і президент тут критикував
доволі жорстко перед самітом так позицію
НАТО ви в кулуарах про це говорите
членам делегації це впливає на них нам
кажуть що ми невдячні Тобто вони кажуть
Ми вам даємо працюємо а ви не вдячний
Я кажу я вдячна вашим
людям я вдячна американським виборцям Я
вдячна виборцям Німеччини Я вдячна
виборцям кожної країни яка відправила
свою зброю свої гроші в Україну але я
також бачу Спілкуючись з звичайними
людьми що підтримка людей
потреби України перемогти набагато
більше ніж підтримка багатьох лідерів
цих країн і
про це ми також говоримо відверто тобто
в Штатах скільки 70% американців
погоджуються з тим що Україна має бути
членом НАТО Фактор виборів може вплинути
на них автор президентських виборів
наступного року Фактор виборів може
вплинути і позитивно і негативно
але взагалі час не на нашій стороні час
на стороні Росії тому що війна на
українській території тому що Росії
потрібен вона зараз Росія слабка їм
потрібен час щоб вивчити свої помилки
натренувати нових своїх солдатів
наклепати більше Дронів іншої зброї
попереганяти по іншим банківським
рахункам свої гроші щоб їх не
конфіскували
розширити свої дезінформаційні
пропагандистські кампанії по країнам
НАТО щоб там вплинути на вибори країн
НАТО і для того щоб підсилити ці
популістичні
антиукраїнські меседжі тому тому Ми
настільки жорсткі зараз і
президент і ми представники
громадянського суспільства з нашими
партнерами Ми кажемо Ну ви нам говорите
про стратегічне терпіння
А що це означає на практиці це означає
нам треба стратегічно терпіти доки ми не
помремо ми не готові до цього аргумент
Ну вони підвисають трошки підвисають і
все тобто вони і потім знову посмішка Я
так розумію ну і борітися поборете як
хто Дея кі Не всі не всі
партнери
бояться Росії у нас є прекрасні друзі в
Литві в нас є прекрасні друзі в інших
балтійських країнах Польщі на кордоні
які розуміють що таке креми дадуть під
каток першими потенційно якщо почнеться
вона Вони не бояться А крини які
знаходяться далеко на заході або навіть
за океаном
вони відірвані трохи від реальності Вони
не розуміють що таке крем що таке розсія
вони не відчувають війну і наше завдання
було тут трішки нагадати їм що таке
війна і що таке люди котрі проживають
війну щодня для багатьох політиків які
приїхали сюди війна - це стрічка в
Твітері або різні звіти Які їхні е-е
картинка по телебаченню розмови
телефонні для нас війна це наші діти які
сплять в ванній кімнаті під час нічних
серан для нас війна - це коли наші
близькі рідні друзі гинуть від
російських снарядів в на полі бою для
нас війна - це коли в тебе рідна людина
з відірваними руками ногами з без очей
для нас фінанси трагедія і нам нема чого
втрачати
Отже будемо сподіватися що країни-члени
НАТО зрозуміють ці Аргументи і не буде
обмежуватися підтримка країна НАТО
стратегічним терпінням проханням про це
А справді не тільки політично поміняти
назву комісія на рада чи якісь всі інші
обіцянки і так далі а буде реальне
запрошення і реальна допомога Отже дякую
пані Дар'я за ваші експерти оцінки
називається переможна Україна тому я
сподіваюся що все ж таки так і відбулися
Отже Дякую що були з нами Мене звати
Максим драбок це було включення пряме
включення з саміту НАТО залишайтеся з
нами більше читайте на наших ресурсах у
соцмережах а також на веб-сайті До
побачення